[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEORGE MACKERRON: Well,
Alex has stolen the content
on my first couple of slides.
So I guess I'm
George, and I'm going
to talk to you about the
economics of happiness
and some of the findings
of my own research.
As Alex says, I've got several
hats, academic economist,
creator of a study called
Mappiness, which is largely
what I'll talk to
you about today,
which I think is the
biggest momentary happiness
study that's been done,
and also, as Alex says,
co-founder of a startup.
So I research election
environment economics
and behavioral economics
and happiness economics.
I also teach PhD students
regular expressions,
but no one knows that they need
to know regular expressions
until they come to my session.
They don't come to my
session because they
don't know they need to
know regular expressions,
despite the fact
that I advertise it
with an XKCD cartoon.
Anyway, I know something
about measuring
and possibly something
about improving happiness.
And as Alex says, I
do a certain amount
of teaching in the
course of all of this.
So today I want to give you a
very brief history of happiness
economics, persuade you that
happiness is worth measuring,
and that happiness measurements
are valid and useful.
And the poster for
this talk promises
to answer this question.
How happy would it make
you be to be drinking
by an estuary in the
vicinity of riots the day
after your football team lost
unexpectedly at a full moon
when Donald Trump had
just won an election?
So I'll do my best to answer
that question as we go along.
And I can tell you right away
that two of those factors
aren't important.
But I'll leave you guessing for
now as to which two those are.
So a very brief history
of happiness economics.
And I'm going to explain
this via a timeline
of old white men, which
given the context is perhaps
not my brightest idea ever.
But anyway, we start
with the 18th century.
And we have Jeremy Bentham.
And reading straight
from Wikipedia,
"Bentham is regarded
as the founder
of modern utilitarianism.
And he defined as the
'fundamental axiom' of his
philosophy the principle that
'it is the greatest happiness
of the greatest number
that's the measure of right
and wrong.'" And so this sort
of hedonic or philosophic
calculus, which Bentham
called it, happiness maths,
is basically a kind of cost
benefit analysis using pleasure
and pain.
So when you're trying to figure
out what action is right,
you should consider the pleasure
and the pains that result
from it, and how intense
they are, how long they last,
how certain you are
of them, how near
they are at hand,
how likely they
are to lead to future
pleasures and pains,
and how many people they
benefit or they hurt.
And then you should consider
all the alternatives.
And that might be the best
way to choose what to do.
Now, around 100 years after
Bentham, we have Edgeworth.
He was the founding editor
of "The Economic Journal,"
and laid lots of the foundations
of sort of modern utility
theory.
And Edgeworth went as far
as to imagine something
that he called a hedonometer,
an idealized happiness measuring
machine.
And he waxed really
lyrical about this
and says "let there be granted
to the science of pleasure what
is granted to the
science of energy.
Imagine an ideally
perfect instrument,
a psychophysical machine,
continually registering
the heights of pleasure
experienced by an individual,
exactly according to the
verdict of consciousness
or rather diverging there from,
according to a law of errors.
From moment to moment,
the hedonometer varies,
the delicate index
now flickering
with the flutter of the
passions, now steadied
by intellectual
activity, low sunk
whole hours in the
neighborhood of zero,
will momentarily spring
up towards infinity."
But unfortunately,
Edgeworth's peers
were mostly not on
board with this idea.
Economists then, in
the early 20th century,
increasingly wanted to be
thought of as scientists.
They had a kind of physics envy.
And they certainly
did not want to be
thought of as psychologists
such as Freud, who we see here.
And therefore, if we look at
Pareto, Pareto, for example,
was very proud of
his Theory of Choice
in which he said that every
psychological analysis is
eliminated.
And he boasts that he's not
interested in the reason
why man is indifferent
between one bundle of goods
and another bundle of goods.
"I notice the pure
and naked fact."
And so words like willpower
and imagination and feelings
began to vanish from economics.
Instead, economists came up with
very elegant and certainly very
useful theories of well-being
as preference satisfaction,
where you're happy to the
extent that you can satisfy
your consumer preferences, and
you can approximate the extent
that you can satisfy you
consumer preferences by how
much income you have.
And therefore the
recommendations
of economists tended towards--
both for individuals
and for nations--
well, do your best
to get richer.
Now, 20th century
economists were not stupid.
And of course,
they're not oblivious
to the potential unintended
consequences of that.
But they have this
special powerful Latin
to protect their
assumptions from that.
So we just say
"ceteris paribus,"
and that means all other
things being equal--
and definitely it's true--
but all other things being
equal, aiming to get richer
is a pretty solid idea.
But around the 1970s,
some economists
started asking awkward
questions on this topic.
And in particular, here
is Richard Easterlin
of the University
of Pennsylvania
and now the University
of Southern California,
who's commonly regarded
as sort of the grandfather
of modern happiness economics.
And Easterlin published a
paper in 1974 with the title
"Does Economic Growth
Improve the Human Lot?"
which was probably the
economists' equivalent of
is the pope Catholic
and do bears
go to the toilet in the woods?
But Easterlin was
sort of looking
to confront this
economic growth data
with some kind of external
measure of happiness.
And in order to do that, he used
self-reported well-being survey
data.
And following Easterlin,
lots of other economists
have taken up this
line of thinking.
And one of the key figures,
certainly, in this country
is Professor Richard Layard,
who is a labor economist at LSC
and a member of
the House of Lords.
Layard wrote an
influential book in 2005
based on some
earlier lectures, and
along with the former cabinet
secretary here, Gus O'Donnell,
has been kind of instrumental
in getting the UK
government to take well-being
measures seriously,
both within the civil service
and in the country at large.
I said Easterlin used
self-reported well-being survey
data.
What is that data?
Well, it's answers to
questions like this.
And actually, these
are the four questions
that the Office for
National Statistics
now asks regularly
across the country
of a representative sample.
How satisfied are you
with your life nowadays?
And this relates
to what we often
call the evaluative
account of well-being,
thinking about your
life as a whole.
It asks what extent do
you feel the things you
do in your life are worthwhile?
And that gets at what we often
call the eudemonic account
of well-being, sense of
meaning, sense of purpose,
sense that what you do in
your life is worthwhile.
And then the last
two questions, how
happy did you feel
yesterday and how
anxious did you
feel yesterday, get
at what we call the
hedonic account, which
goes back to Aristotle, as in
fact the eudemonic account does
too.
That's sometimes sort
of rather deprecatingly
referred to as
smiley face feeling.
It's kind of mood,
emotion, in the moment,
the most immediate kind
of measure of happiness.
Now, all three of these
accounts of well-being
are very highly correlated.
You know, you'd
expect that people
who have enjoyable moments feel
satisfied with their lives,
for example, although there are
some interesting divergences.
Having kids might cause you to
have an interesting divergence
in some of these.
You might get very high highs
but also some fairly low lows.
You might feel that your
life has more purpose.
It might affect
things differently.
By and large they move
together, but there
are some things that can move
them somewhat separately.
Economists have
mostly just looked
at the evaluative
account, because it's
really easy to get ahold of.
It's one question, and
you can ask it today,
and you can ask it next
week and next month
and you'll get a similar answer.
So you can sort of
shove it into any survey
that you're asking people.
And it's also the one
that's most closely
related to people's income,
which makes economists
feel comfortable with it.
My own project,
Mappiness, is actually
primarily a hedonic
measure of happiness.
And not just how happy
you felt yesterday,
but how happy do
you feel right now.
And I will talk a whole
lot more about that soon.
A key question that comes up
in economics and elsewhere
is very simple.
Is this valid?
Is this meaningful?
Can people really reduce
the quality of their life
to 0 to 10 scale?
And certainly within
economics there
remains an amount of
controversy about this.
There are certainly
economists who are quite
wedded to the preference
satisfaction view,
and to their indifference
curves, and to not
getting involved in the messy
business of how people feel.
And in reducing the quality
of your life experience to a 0
to 10 scale, we can certainly
be accused of reductionism.
It is a kind of
reductionist enterprise.
And I'm not for a minute
saying that's the only way
that we should seek to
understand people's life
experiences.
But my view is certainly that
the subjective well-being
ratings are valid enough
and meaningful enough
to tell us interesting
and valuable things.
And for one thing, there's
a lot of convergeability.
Lots of other things point
very much in the same way.
For example, subjective
well-being responses
are very strongly correlated
with objective indicators,
including neural
activity from fMRI scans.
Biochemical markers,
such as levels
of cortisol in the blood,
heart rate, blood pressure,
smiling, other people's ratings
of a person's well-being.
They're a strong predictor
of people's future behavior.
And subjective
well-being ratings
are also very highly
correlated with income.
Certainly they're very
highly correlated with income
if you look at a single
country at one time.
The income relationship
is sort of less clear cut
if you look between countries.
And we could talk
about this all day.
These charts are
sort of interesting.
So these are actually
the same charts.
One of them is on a log scale.
One of them is on
a linear scale.
And the choice of which
one of these you plot
is actually potentially
quite political.
If you plot this
one, you kind of
make very clear that Robin
Hood was doing a good thing,
because up here,
very little happiness
distinction between
people earning
$100,000 versus $150,000.
Down here a very large happiness
distinction between people
with a much smaller
differential.
So if you ever look at the
Institute for Economic Affairs
report, for example, they'll
always plot this one.
But there is a strong
relationship within a country.
Now, you do need to
be careful when you're
comparing between individuals.
And certainly you
need to careful
when you're comparing
values between countries.
But you can get a lot
of mileage even out
of just the changes within each
individual's own responses.
And that's actually primarily
what my research relies on.
So I would certainly
argue that this
is a valid and a useful
way to look at the world.
Some of you may be
saying, back up a bit,
didn't I see an fMRI
scan a few slides ago?
Wouldn't that be the gold
standard scientific way
to measure happiness?
You know, it's got big
machines, costs lots of money,
spits out hard numbers.
Give me a break from this
hand-wavy social sciencey
question asking stuff.
But actually, no.
Because happiness
is fundamentally
a completely subjective thing.
It's part of an
individual's experience.
The only reason that we know
what the fMRI scans mean
and we can interpret them
in terms of happiness
is because at some
point in the past,
we put people in fMRI
machines and we asked them
how happy they were while we
were scanning their brains.
So you can make
quite a strong case
that actually, the gold
standard for knowing
how happy people are
is just to ask them.
You might also remember
that I promised
that subjective well-being
data could tell us
valuable and interesting things.
So what kinds of
things would be?
Well, there's at
least three ways
that economists might want to
use subjective well-being data.
One of them is very
simply to test and refine
other economic theory.
There's this kind of
tautological sense in economics
that what do people
want is what they do.
And what they do, well,
it's what they want.
And you can't really get
out of that very easily
in this kind of revealed
preference, almost
kind of behaviorist,
way of figuring out what
people want in their lives.
But if you can measure
their happiness,
you can tell if people do
seem to make the choices that
make them happier, or
whether they systematically
mispredict what's going
to make them happiest.
And there's lots
of good evidence
that they do
systematically mispredict,
and they don't make
the choices that
would have appeared to make
them happy in retrospect.
You can discriminate
between models
that have different
underlying utilities
but look the same in terms
of people's behavior.
Becker has an idea of
rational addiction, where
given a certain
set of preferences,
people can rationally
become addicted to drugs.
It's very difficult
to distinguish
that when you look at
people's behavior from people
just lacking
self-control and not
being in control of
the choices they make.
But if you can
observe how they feel,
then you might be
able to discriminate
which of those is in fact the
explanation for the behavior
that you see.
And speaking today,
having just been
to your canteen, situations
where people are happier
having less choice,
which is sort
of paradoxical and impossible
in standard economic theory,
because more choice
always kind of less choice
is nested within it.
And more choice must be better.
But it's certainly the
case that sometimes there
are situations
where we are happier
having less choice, just one or
two things to choose for lunch.
Or I was in a situation where
I got taken somewhere flying
business class at one point.
And it was amazing.
And then the next time they
offered to pay me the money,
and then I had to make
a choice whether to fly
business class or not.
And that cost me an awful lot
of anguish, because the price is
ridiculous.
And on the other hand,
I kind of enjoyed it.
So there are
certainly situations
where we're happy having no
choice, which don't make sense
in normal economics.
But subjective well-being data
might help you understand them.
And there are probably more
things than this you can do.
But the third of the things
I was going to talk about
are that we can
value things and we
can sense the
importance of things
that aren't traded in markets.
And this might be things
that you really just
couldn't trade in markets
at all, like marriage.
And there is a paper
that finds that marriage
is extraordinarily valuable
if you try and turn it
into an income equivalent
in terms of people's
subjective well-being.
And also, for example,
the environment,
which in certain areas can
be kind of traded in markets.
And you can at least
ask people to imagine
that it's traded in markets.
But nevertheless, that
isn't always very strong
information on how people
do value the environment
and how it makes them feel.
And that brings
me to my research.
And this is the
logo for Mappiness,
which was an iPhone app that
launched in 2010 as part
of my PhD at LSC.
And this is, in a
sense, quite a good day
to take stock of this
project, since actually
the release of iOS
11 yesterday marks
the moment when Mappiness just
stops working more or less
everywhere.
The code was written for iOS 3.
This was pre automatic
reference counting, and pre
almost everything else.
So the background.
What Mappiness is for is
looking at the impact--
was originally,
certainly-- looking
at the impact of natural
environments on people's
happiness.
Here's green space.
Same slide, I think, that
was behind all the logos
at the beginning.
And we can all agree that green
space, hopefully, is nice.
It makes us feel good.
And I once went to a
geography conference
where no one said anything
else for three days.
That's fine as far as it goes.
But it doesn't go all that
far, because what is actually
kind of useful to know
is just how lovely
is green space, right?
Policy makers want
to spend money
on all kinds of
different things.
They can't spend all their
money on green space.
And so it's helpful to them to
have some quantitative sense
of the loveliness
of green space,
also blue space, other kinds
of natural environment.
So how much happier are people
in natural environments?
Economists looking at
this have generally
done big observational studies.
And they've looked at
countrywide averages
of happiness and environment.
Or they've looked at
people's general happiness
on the individual level in
relation to where they live
and their immediate
surroundings.
There are some problems
with those approaches.
So what I kind of set out
in the PhD thinking was,
wouldn't it be nice
if we could look
at the experiences
of individuals
at particular moments in time?
So not just how happy
do you feel in general
and where do you live, but how
happy do you feel right now,
and where are you right now?
And that will give you
some really direct data
on the link between
happiness and environment.
And it would need to be that
hedonic account of happiness,
that smiley face
feeling, because that's
the thing that varies sort
of minute by minute and hour
by hour.
If you were to ask
people how satisfied
they were with their
life as a whole
in different environments,
you wouldn't probably
get very much if you tried
to do that every day.
Now, looking at people's
momentary experiences
has been done for many
years in psychology
and also in medicine.
In psychology, these are called
Experience Sampling Method
studies.
In medicine, they're called
Ecological Momentary Assessment
studies.
And Alex tells me,
actually, that some of you
are running something very much
like a Ecological Momentary
Assessment study at the
moment, using watches.
But in the classic ESM
survey, certainly when
these things were come
up with decades ago,
you would give out
notebooks or PDAs.
You beeped people
at random moments,
and you asked people
about their experience
and the context of
their experience.
And the benefit of this,
you get no recall bias.
You get an accurate and
detailed record of experience
that isn't affected
by the things
that, for example,
Kahneman talks about,
about the peak/end rule and
all of the kinds of biases.
There's an interesting
philosophical question,
actually, about
whether you are more
interested in what
you experience
or what you remember.
But certainly you
can make an argument
that it's nice to have no
recall bias in this data.
And we get panel data.
We get longitudinal data.
And that means we can
do fixed effects models,
where we only use the
variation within an individual.
And that's a big benefit.
If you want to think
about that benefit,
here's a green space in London,
Buckingham Palace Gardens.
And if we went and found
that responses from people
in Buckingham Palace Gardens
were generally happier
than the average, you
might want to argue
that the kind of people you find
in Buckingham Palace Gardens
are not quite the
same as the average,
and more likely to have
just been bought a yacht
by the taxpayer, for example.
There are all kinds
of reasons why
those people might be happier.
But with the fixed
effects model,
when we're looking only
within individual variation,
we can tell that the same people
in Buckingham Palace Gardens
are happier than
when those people are
on the other side
of the wall facing
lots of buses driving past them
on their bicycle, for example.
And so this is a
kind of powerful way
of looking at this,
because we get
to use that within
individual variation
and take out effects that say
that certain people are found
in nice environments and
those are different people
than go elsewhere.
And then around this time with
the PhD, the iPhone launched.
And then apps became
available for the iPhone.
And this seemed a
great tool to us.
So ESM studies
began in the '70s,
and they were kind
of difficult to run,
because you had to
give out these diaries.
You had to give
out these pagers.
And they found that
in some studies,
almost half the people
filled in all the diaries
at the beginning to get it out
of the way with, or at the end,
because they realized
they haven't done it yet.
And it's a real
logistical challenge,
whereas with the iPhone and
now with other similar devices
which I'm told exist,
you've got GPS.
You've got a microphone
for sound levels.
You can send the data back
using a mobile data connection.
You can interrupt people
with a noise at any moment.
You can even have them take
a picture of the environment.
And of course almost everyone
now has one of these things.
And there was a problem, which
is that certain kinds of people
have iPhones.
And I suppose certain kinds of
people have Android phones too.
Certainly in 2010, iPhone
owners are on average
sort of young and
rich and educated.
And they have to
self-select into the study.
And then they have to be
able and willing to respond
to a beep.
So certainly, we don't
have anything approaching
a representative sample.
And you can grill me on
that later if you want to.
But if I do want to take
part, then 2010, 2011, 2012,
which is when most of
our respondents are for,
it's a free download
in the app store.
I spend two or three
minutes signing up.
And then I get dinged.
And then I spend sort of
30 seconds or so responding
to a series of questions.
I say how happy I am.
And that's mostly
the data that we use.
That's mostly the dependent
variable in the regressions
that I'll tell you
about in a minute.
And then I report a
few control variables
which sometimes
turn out to be quite
interesting in their own right.
But I say who I'm
with, what I'm doing.
I think at this point that I'm
imagining that I'm in a pub.
And this will relate to one of
the things I talk about later.
And then all the
data gets sent back.
I can look at my
data in the app,
get some very
simple information.
I think actually
just being caused
to reflect on your
happiness twice a day
is more powerful, probably,
than a few simple charts.
There's also a sort
of adjacent API
where I can build
things off this.
And there's even a kind
of an online section
where I can look at my
data on the Google map.
I can view charts.
I can look at all my
pictures, and so on.
And there's me working on
Mappiness website, I think.
The project got really
good media coverage.
I was sort of thinking,
this is a PhD.
I might get 100 people
doing it for two weeks.
That would be fine
for a PhD thesis.
But actually, we
launched in August,
which was a great idea, because
nothing happens in August.
And so we got really nice
coverage, interview on CNN,
front page of "Le Figaro,"
not quite so useful
because we're not
targeting France.
But anyway, Tuesday
is worse than Monday,
and that's a really big story.
Featured in the app
store, so that now we
have more than 4
million responses
from about 66,000 people.
And if I give you some sort
of very simple descriptive,
this is the first year of
data and a half hour moving
average of how happy
people report being.
It's a little bit
washed out at the top,
but the left I think
starts at 8:00 AM,
and the right ends at 10:00 AM.
And then there's a
sort of horizontal line
per day through the year from
the beginning of September 2010
to the end of August 2011.
And a few patterns
might jump out at you.
Firstly, it's stripey.
And the stripes are weekends.
So you can see lighter
colors are happier.
Weekends are enormously
happier than weekdays.
There's a kind of really
bright spot around here,
which is Christmas.
And there's a really
bright spot around here
which is sort of the
May bank holidays.
We get a little bit lighter
as we go from the left
to the right, which tells
you that, on average, people
get happier throughout the day.
And you can also see that the
second half is a little bit
noisier than the
first half, so you
can tell that we had slightly
more respondents in this period
than we did in this period.
This actually now
goes over the whole 6
and 1/2 years up to the
beginning of this year.
It's probably too
small to see, which
is sort of vaguely
intentional, because I still
haven't published this.
But you can see these
peaks are all Christmases.
Christmases are always good.
There's a general
downward tendency.
I don't know whether we should
make anything of that or not.
It might just be that
different kinds of people
were signed up later than
were signed up earlier.
So maybe some face
validity for saying
that people are a little
bit less happy now
than they were in 2010?
But I couldn't guarantee
you that from the data.
A few other events
that we can spot.
Murray winning Wimbledon
here on a hot day.
Hot days of above
about 25 degrees,
you get a really big
spike in happiness.
Other weather variables
make a difference, but not
such a big difference.
But really hot
weather is very good.
Olympic opening
ceremony, royal wedding,
annoying for Republicans.
And you probably
can't read this,
but it relates to
one of the questions.
This is the worst,
the least happy day
that we recorded over the
whole of the 6 and 1/2 years.
And this is the news
that Trump got elected
as the president of America.
This is, I think,
the Brexit result.
I think that's the
fourth least happy day.
Now, you might say
this just shows you
that Mappiness users
are not representative
of the population.
On the other hand,
referendum voters
are not representative
of the population either.
And Mappiness voters
have great taste.
So I seem to have made
a more political point
than I intended.
Planning to use this to
create a happiness forecast
at some point.
And I've been planning
this for a long time.
But there's this idea of
Blue Monday every year.
It's the second
Monday in January.
They kind of wheel out the guy
who came up with Blue Monday.
And sometimes they
wheel me out to say
that Blue Monday is rubbish.
But we've got no evidence that
the second Monday in January
is anything particularly bad.
If anything, it looks
like a Tuesday in November
might be the worst day
of the year on average.
But I hope to have news on
that in the near future.
Now, in Mappiness I was
interested in green spaces.
And so as an incredibly
naive first approach,
this is measuring the
number of green pixels
in each of the pictures
that people take.
These are the colors that
I'm counting as green.
And this is some indication
of how many pixels there
are in each one.
It was done very
simply in processing.
Interestingly, the
amount of green
is very strongly
correlated with happiness
before we control
for anything else.
So no green pixels
to all green pixels
gives you about six points
out of 100 jump in happiness.
I'm not sure we can read
very much into that,
because the effect
goes away when
we control for other things.
It might well be, for
example, that people really
don't like work and that
workplaces generally don't
have a lot of green in them.
And it could be
as simple as that.
I've also been thinking
about deep learning
for image classification.
There's about 300,000
photos, so that could be fun.
I'm sure there's lots of
other kinds of deep learning
that can be done with this data.
But for the PhD, and the more
serious analysis in the PhD,
I joined up habitat data
with each response location.
And this is an extract
from the Land Cover Map
2000, which is a high resolution
remote sense satellite
data set.
This is London, so you
can see a lot of black,
which is continuous urban.
But you can also see the river.
You can also see Hyde
Park as a mixture of trees
and grassland and so on.
So this is not about
country versus city.
It's very much about land
cover wherever it occurs.
And then all the information
that we collected
goes into one big
regression model.
So it predicts happiness from
naught to 100 on the left,
with on the right the
habitat that you're in,
the weather conditions, the
daylight, who you're with,
what you're doing, what kind of
place you're in, time of day,
day of the week, how many
responses you've given before,
because we find that people
get happier over time,
and we use individual
fixed effects to take out
that average effect
of being each person.
And these all go in together.
And that means that each
effect is controlled
for every other effect.
That's important, because when
you're out in a green space,
it might also be
sunny, and you might
be playing Frisbee
with your mates,
and it might be the
weekend, and so on.
So this all goes together to
this big regression model.
To get a feel for the
size of the effects,
you can look at the happiest
and the least happy activities.
The top activity
is one that I added
after many emailed requests.
There may be people looking
over people's shoulder
at this point, so we take
that one with a pinch of salt.
But you can see
that generally it's
sort of physical activities
and cultural activities
and social activities that
seem to occupy the top spots.
And most of these
give a give a bump
of sort of four to
six points out of 100
in people's happiness.
We've got plenty of data, and
so these are the 95% confidence
intervals.
So these are very
significant effects.
And then the focus of the
research, which was land cover.
And we find this
land cover type,
marine and coastal margins.
People were enormously happier
in marine and coastal margins
than anywhere else.
This is all relative.
Zero here is being in
an urban environment.
So people are on average about
six points happier in what's
effectively an estuary.
This is a kind of an
estuary environment,
marine and coastal margins.
It's not any coastline.
But in any other
natural environment,
they're also
significantly happier
than they would be in
an urban environment
after we've controlled
for all the other things
that we can think of.
And this stands up to a number
of different robustness checks
and some completely
different ways of defining
a natural environment.
So it works very
similarly if we use
areas of outstanding natural
beauty, national nature
reserves, and one other
the classification
that I forget now.
But different kind of
administrative classifications
of countryside give us sort
of similar sized results.
And people are happier in
those than they are outside.
And so this was reported in a
paper in the journal "Global
Environmental Change."
A strong line of evidence
on links between environment
and happiness.
Slightly ambitious title.
This is only the UK.
It's not representative.
But anyway, we've got some
nice quantitative evidence
on this point.
And that's nice,
because we all probably,
as I said at the
beginning, realize
that people like green spaces.
But this generally sounds a
little bit soft and intangible
and perhaps doesn't
stop the government
proposing to
privatize our forests
or allowing them to bulldoze
sites of scientific interest
for golf courses and so on.
And so the more hard
quantitative data
we've got on this, perhaps
the better the chance
we might have in saving some
of the environmental treasures
that we've got.
So we've covered
being by an estuary.
That's really good.
And we've covered Donald Trump
winning the election, which
is very bad.
We've got a number of
things left in this list
that I promised you.
Any of you that
are werewolves will
be interested to
know that I don't
find any effect of the full moon
or any other phase of the moon,
although I do have to control
quite carefully for other time
variables in order to not get
interesting false positives
on that point.
And that leaves us with
drinking, riots, and football.
Unsurprisingly, we do find
that alcohol, drinking alcohol,
makes people happier in the
moment than when you're not
drinking alcohol.
And that's after controlling
for lots of the things that
go along with drinking alcohol,
such as probably not working,
being with friends, being
in a pub, and so on.
And we also see it
making you tired
the next day, which
is not rocket science.
These were back of the
envelope calculations
for the cabinet office
who were looking
for evidence of the
benefits of local pubs
as sort of community hubs.
These, again, are fixed
effects regression results
controlling for a whole
range of other things.
And we don't know what
people are drinking.
We don't know how
much they're drinking.
But we do find a big
positive effect of drinking,
six points out of
100 in happiness.
And that's very significant.
And then we have some
other interaction.
Drinking in the pub is
better, drinking on your own
is significantly
worse, and so on.
Now, that's the basis
of another paper.
And, of course, that's not
the whole of the well-being
story with alcohol, right?
We saw negative coefficients
on drinking alone, drinking
on a weekday morning.
There are, of course,
drinkers and non drinkers
who have their lives
wrecked by alcohol.
But the positive effects
are part of the story.
And actually, some
recent research work
and some recent
policy work often
can entirely neglect to
mention the positive reasons
why people drink as well.
So it is useful to be
able to quantify those.
And that's the point
that my coauthor Ben
Bamburg makes in this paper.
I have very little
interest in football,
but some of my colleagues at
Sussex are football fanatics.
And it seems to be a source of
strong emotion for some people,
judging by these quotes
that I've picked out.
And so we figured out that
actually with the Mappiness
data, we can look at this.
And we have responses like
this one, which occurs here,
kind of very close to
the football stands,
middle of the afternoon
on a Saturday.
And the individual reports that
they're at a match or sporting
event.
So we found a data set with the
locations of football stadiums.
We found another data set
that has match dates, results,
and the bookmakers' odds.
And we did a little
bit of web scraping
to find the exact kickoff
times of those matches.
And then we could join all
that together to figure out
who seem to be keen football
supporters, which teams they
follow.
Ideally you spot them
at two different matches
with one team in common and
then you're reasonably certain.
And we get 100 or
200 people that way.
And we get a few
hundred more if we just
assume that people are probably
supporting the home team.
And then we can follow those
people's happiness level
throughout the season.
We're not limited
just to the matches
that we spot on the map.
And this is actually a paper
that I'm working on right now.
And what we find is
interesting and very much
in line with sort of the
behavioral economics on loss
aversion.
So we find that a win is sort
of niceish for an hour or two.
A loss is really bad.
It's much more negative
than a win is positive.
And not only is it much worse,
it also lasts much longer.
So you can still
see the next morning
that people are unhappy
if their team lost,
even more so if they
didn't see it coming.
So if you also have an
interaction in there
for the bookies' odds being
that they were going to win,
and then they lost, that
makes it even more painful.
And actually, this does have
some quite interesting sort
of real world outcomes as well.
There was a paper in
the "Quarterly Journal
of Economics" about
American football
and looking at domestic
violence that came out
with very strong findings.
And we may also be able to
look at people's behavior.
We haven't done this yet,
but kind of quite interested
to find out whether
it has any effect
on the probability of showing
up at work the next day.
So that leaves us with
riots, I think, of the things
that I promised to
talk to you about.
And this is work that was
done by my PhD student
[? Panka ?] [INAUDIBLE]
who wanted to be here,
but unfortunately isn't
quite back from the States
on a Fulbright scholarship.
This follows on
from some work where
we looked at
happiness impacts sort
of rippling over time and
space from terrorist incidents
in Northern Ireland.
So [? Panka ?] took
the Mappiness data
and was looking for
a sort of signature
from the riots that happened in
August 2011 in English cities.
And if you weren't here
or you don't remember,
there were sort of
several days of looting
and setting fire to things and
clashing with the police that
started, I think, in
Hackney, and spread
to other parts of London and
then the country as a whole.
Now, that seemed
reasonably promising to me,
because I was living close
to Elephant and Castle
at the time, and I remember
that we were planning to go out
to a restaurant and then we
thought maybe the Elephant
and Castle shopping
center isn't the best
place to be at this point.
So I thought you'd have seen
it in my happiness data.
[? Panka ?] hasn't
actually managed
to find this in the Mappiness
data, which I don't think
is her fault. I think
we just don't see it.
All that we do
see is that we can
see that people are watching
telly a little bit more
over this period,
which is potentially
people keeping track with
what's going on on the news.
We're not quite sure.
But as far as we can
tell, these riots
don't have an impact on
your average Mappiness user.
So that's all the things
that I promised you,
but how are you doing today?
Well, the bad news, obviously,
is that you're at work.
And of all the things
that you could be doing,
work ranks second only to
sickness as a cause of misery.
These are all the
activities that people
can report doing in Mappiness.
There's about 40 of them.
And here is working or studying.
And we can restrict this
just to the people who
say that they're
in full time work,
and we find that has quite a
big negative coefficient, second
only to being ill in bed,
which is rather bigger.
That's 20 points out of 100,
but work is still minus 5.
And in fact, it's not just
being in the workplace.
The working day and working
are independently negative.
I can't remember how
colleagues turn out.
Maybe I shouldn't say anyway.
This is work with
Alex Bryson at UCL.
And we also look at what you're
doing while you're working.
And we find, in fact,
that only 0.3% of people
follow Snow White's
advice, which
is a pity, because the
happiness effects of singing
and performing would be just
about enough to wipe out
the negative effects of
working, although the effects
on your coworkers might also
need to be factored in there,
I suppose.
So there were two other things
that I want to mention today
in terms of what
we've been doing
and what we're going to do next.
And I mention these two
things particularly just
in case anyone here
is sort of interested
and potentially could help out.
Now, this is a bit washed out.
And so my PhD
student, [? Panka ?]
is now sort of turning her
attention to air pollution.
And we've got really
good reason to think
that air pollution will affect
people's subjective well-being,
including routes via
their physical health.
We've also got
really good reason
to think that it will impair
their physical and cognitive
abilities.
There's a really amazing
paper last year from LSE
by Sefi Soth, where he gives
quite convincing evidence,
having kind of put air
pollution monitors in the exam
rooms at LSE, that high levels
of particulates in the exam
room increase students'
probability of failing
their exam by about 5%.
And he has the same students
sitting different exams
in different rooms at
different levels of pollution
so that the identification is
quite convincing in that one.
Now, I raise this possibility
of a link between air pollution
and performance because
one thing that occurs to us
is that Google has really rich
data on some kinds of cognitive
and perhaps also physical
performance, for example, maybe
mistyped searches, mistyped
words on Android keyboard,
and so on.
And these data presumably could
be located in space and time.
And that means that
potentially they
could be related
to air pollution
data to look for potentially
causal relationships.
And in cities like
London and lots
of American cities, different
places around the world,
there's quite good data now
on air pollution through space
and over time.
So if you can think
of any data that
would help us
understand air pollution
effects on performance, then do
let me know at the end of today
or on email or via Alex.
It doesn't necessarily have
to be big things, you know,
thinking about a simple typo.
A simple typo has been enough in
various situations in the past
to administer a near
fatal drug dose.
To lop several nines off
the availability of S-3,
we'll have the world
believing that there's
an order of magnitude more
iron in spinach than in fact
is in spinach, which is the
origin of the Popeye cartoons.
So even small things, I think,
could be really interesting
there.
And the other thing I was going
to talk about, which as I say
is sort of apposite on the day
after Mappiness kind of goes
dark, is Mappiness 2.
And there are sort of three
things that distinguish,
we hope, this next iteration
of Mappiness, which I'm already
working on, from the original.
Firstly, it will be
on iPhone and Android,
and we hope it will add in
some fun stuff like heart rate
variability measurement
with the camera
and flash which, I discover,
Alex and some of his team
know an awful lot about.
Integration, probably,
with HealthKit and perhaps
equivalents on Android, which
I'd be happy to talk about.
It will try to not only
quantify your happiness--
and as I said, we do find
that the process of reflecting
through doing
Mappiness for a while
does seem to make
people happier--
but also to improve
your happiness.
Now the idea in the
original Mappiness
was just that we wanted data,
so we kind of didn't want
to change people's happiness.
Obviously it's a good thing
that people's happiness went up
rather than down,
or we'd have a lot
of trouble getting ethical
approval for any future study.
But it's a little bit cold in
that you can tell Mappiness
that you're really miserable
day after day after day,
and Mappiness the original
does nothing about it.
My co-founder at Psychological
Technologies, Nick Begley,
was the first
employee at Headspace,
and so he knows plenty
about mindfulness
and other sorts of
scientifically validated
approaches to making
people feel better.
So the idea is that in the
next Mappiness, if you're not
feeling good, we can
begin to offer you
suggestions for the
kinds of things that
might make you feel better.
And for example, we have
mental and physical well-being
interventions that are
integrated in Mappiness 2,
like this sort of interactive
mindfulness practice.
And we can suggest them
at appropriate moments.
And even better,
hopefully over time,
we can collect data on what the
most appropriate moments are
for which kinds of interventions
and how those are going
to make people feel better.
And the third thing
that's new in Mappiness
is more of a focus on work.
So as I said, the
first Mappiness
found that people
aren't happy at work.
And that wasn't what
we set out to do.
And we therefore didn't
collect lots of the data
that you'd probably
most want to try and dig
in to that in more detail.
You know, we don't know
what sector or even
what company people are working
in, what they do at work,
anything about what they
think about their employer,
and so on.
And this is
obviously information
that employers are interested
in and that employers
could use to make the
workplace better and make
people happier at work, as well
as perhaps more productive.
So we already have employees
in one big household name
firm using what's effectively
a kind of an alpha version
of Mappiness 2.
But we're also looking for
people, and indeed workplaces,
who would like to
help us conduct
some kind of randomized
controlled trial on the impacts
of this sort of technology,
measuring and then trying
to improve people's
well-being through the apps
in their pockets.
So that's it, but
hopefully there's
plenty of time
for any questions,
if you've got any questions.
And thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: We do have
time for questions.
Please raise your hands.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Quick question.
Have you looked at the
cultural or ethnic component?
Does this apply to everybody of
all ages, and things like that?
GEORGE MACKERRON: That's
a very good question.
We don't ask questions
about ethnic origin,
and we're primarily
looking in the UK,
so unfortunately I don't
have much data on that.
We do ask some demographic
questions, age, gender,
marital status, employment
status, and so on.
Now, generally, the analysis
that I've shown you here
have been these
fixed effect things.
And so all these individual
level things drop out,
and we're just looking at
the average across everyone.
We have looked a
little bit, I think,
at some gender differences
and some age differences.
And in a lot of cases,
there isn't any single thing
significant, and in some other
cases, there's not very much.
I'm a little bit hazy
now on the answers.
Now, there's definitely
scope to do more there.
You could do more with
the data that we've got.
You would ideally, actually,
ask some more questions as well.
I mean, the focus on
Mappiness, really,
was let's look at
natural environment,
and let's make it
so quick and easy
that possibly some people
will want to do it.
So in retrospect,
there's quite a lot
of things that would
be nice to look at.
I mean, do you have any
hypotheses about what
you might find in any of that?
AUDIENCE: No, I mean,
there [INAUDIBLE]
some cultural components
to how somebody perceives
drinking in some cultures
versus how somebody perceives
drinking in a cultural context.
And that can affect the--
GEORGE MACKERRON:
No, that's right.
So I guess results
that I show you today
are kind of valid for the
subset of people in the UK
that we've got.
And you're right, actually.
That's certainly a
good example where
you would have some
different effects, I'm sure.
SPEAKER ONE: More questions?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is there any more you
can say about people seemingly
being very happy at Christmas?
Because my experience is
that everyone moans about how
terrible Christmas is.
GEORGE MACKERRON: So, I
suppose a lot of it turns out,
I think, to come back
to how likely people are
to be working.
And I suspect that
happiness at Christmas
is partly driven by
the fact that we've
got the least number of people
working throughout the year.
We see bank holidays as
being very positive as well.
Beyond that, it's just
anecdotes, isn't it?
I mean, it would be good
to do qualitative research
in some of this stuff.
And I guess that's not my area.
There's perhaps a slight worry
about whether people don't
report if they're not
happy at Christmas
because they feel
like they should be,
or if they misrepresent
their happiness at Christmas,
again because they feel that
that's the time that they're
supposed to be happy.
They don't want to
admit that they're not.
I mean, if you
were going to find
that in any kind of
well-being research,
hopefully you wouldn't
find it in this,
which is a very kind of private
thing with you and your phone.
It's not someone ringing
you up and asking questions.
But yeah, it's a good question.
People have sometimes sort of
expressed surprise at that,
and sort of said, hmm,
people spending a lot of time
with their family isn't always
a recipe for high happiness.
So, yeah, it's a good question.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I think the
obvious question is are people
otherwise happier when
they're spending time
with their family?
GEORGE MACKERRON: And they are.
Yeah.
But I mean, the
things that we looked
at where happiness was amazing,
that was not controlled.
That was just sort
of raw averages.
So you're right that if we
sort of start taking out
the variation that
we can predict,
then you will see those peaks
drop almost certainly, right?
Because they're
with their family.
They're drinking.
Probably some of
them are drinking.
And they're doing other
things that they enjoy.
And they're not working.
Yeah.
So some of it's--
AUDIENCE: --they're not lying.
GEORGE MACKERRON: Right.
OK.
So that's certainly
in line with-- yeah.
Yeah.
And I mean, it's an average
effect, so you would need,
I guess, as long as 2/3
of the people are happier,
1/3 of the people
could be less happy,
and the average coefficient
here comes out the way
that we've seen.
So there's also
certainly scope here
for looking more at
the distribution,
and maybe doing
quantile regression
and seeing what drives
the low responses
versus the high responses, say.
Always in these talks
there's a million things
that I have to apologize
for not having done.
There's a lot still to do.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So with the
fixed effects model,
you're sort of
looking at differences
within individual people.
Like they're happier when
they're in a green area.
But I mean, is
there some concern
that people might adapt
to these interventions?
Like maybe the government
puts green spaces everywhere
and there's still
a big difference,
but instead of being really
happy in green spaces and just
kind of meh in city
urban environments,
now I'm used to green spaces
and urban environments
are just really terrible?
AUDIENCE: Or bitter,
because of the difference.
GEORGE MACKERRON: Yeah.
And I guess related
to that, there's
a question of sort of contrasts.
And so most of our
respondents live in cities.
And so maybe it's partly that
they're getting out of the city
and they're going on holiday.
And that's actually
the number one
question that I wish we'd
asked, is are you on holiday?
And we can kind of
try and get to that
with various heuristics,
but we don't quite have it.
So that's an obvious
thing to try and get at,
also looking at people who
perhaps live in the countryside
and then visit the city.
That's sort of one of
the top things on my list
to stop apologizing for
not having done and do.
And I promised a book
chapter later this year,
actually, where my plan is to do
that amongst some other things.
In general in the
happiness research,
sort of habituation
or adaptation
is certainly an issue.
And I mean, one
of the things that
drove me to do this was I moved
down to London to do the PhD.
I was previously in
Cambridge at that point.
And Cambridge was
green and quite clean.
And London was incredibly
kind of dirty and polluted.
And that kind of got me down.
By the end of five,
six years in London,
I was getting-- at
least, I was aware
of it getting me down less.
So no, that is a question.
And that is certainly a
question for policymakers.
You know, there's all
kinds of other things
people adapt to as well.
You know, they adapt to sort
of chronic health problems
that the government
thinks it's worth spending
quite a lot of money to avoid.
Those then don't seem to
affect people's happiness
in the very long run as
much as you'd expect.
One of the reasons
for that might
be that happiness
isn't the only thing
that people are interested in.
And in fact, the
football research
also talks to that idea
that happiness might not
be the only thing that
people are interested in.
Because unless everyone
supports teams that always win,
which I'm pretty
sure isn't true,
then losses are so
much more painful
than wins are pleasant that
you'd think that they weren't
maximizing the sort of the
integral of their happiness
by going to football
matches and following them.
So that's a bit of a rambling
answer, but it kind of-- yeah.
Your point is still
valid and interesting.
What you'd, I
guess, like to do is
have some kind of,
again, some kind
of trial, some kind of random
assignment of more or less
green space.
See what happens if a park
ends up being closed for a year
to the people who
live nearby, say.
And then you might look
at the profile over time.
If there is some adaptation,
how much is there?
I suspect that it
wouldn't be complete.
There are lots of
other things that--
the reasons that we think
people like green spaces,
you would imagine
perhaps wouldn't go away.
So you know, there's
an opportunity
for sort of physical exercise
that improves health.
There's an opportunity for
socializing with people.
And there's also this idea
that we evolved in the savanna,
or on the edge of
forests, or wherever
it is that we evolved over
tens of thousands of years.
It might well be something
that just kind of causes
us to find these patterns in
our visual system and kind
of attractive,
You this biophilia
hypothesis of Eo Wilson.
So I would be surprised
if all of those
were totally adapted away.
But it would certainly be
interesting to find out
how far they were.
AUDIENCE: There's a new
park in East London, right,
during the time period
that you studied?
GEORGE MACKERRON:
Yeah, the Olympic Park.
Yeah, we should look at that.
We have briefly looked
at the Olympics,
mainly with the ax to grind that
I wonder if it would have been
an awful lot cheaper just to
have a couple of extra bank
holidays.
Might not turn out to be true.
I haven't really checked
in enough detail.
I suspect that we don't
have enough responses
from that time.
And there aren't enough
people living around it.
Because they're also
kind of building-- well,
I guess the houses have just
been built, haven't they?
People have presumably all just
kind of moved there as well,
because it was a sort
of big redevelopment.
It's an interesting thought.
It's the right kind
of thing, I think,
for us to think
about looking it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, sorry.
You had sports and doing sports
as one of the top things that
drives happiness.
But also drinking alcohol,
as well, was on that list.
Just wondering about the trade
off between like virtuous
behaviors and then
maybe not so virtuous
behaviors and how
they impact happiness.
GEORGE MACKERRON: Yeah, I'm
not sure I have anything
very intelligent to say about
that, apart from that, yes,
it does sound interesting.
And I suppose if
we've got people
that we observe over
a long period of time,
then we could
potentially, I suppose,
look at that kind of
cumulative effect of what
you've been doing.
I mean, one of the things that
actually I don't do at all here
is you don't have
any dynamic models.
So we kind of account
for the responses
being from the same
people in the era.
But we don't use the fact
that we could kind of,
this next response follows
the previous response.
And so, in general,
we could kind of both
do that on a kind
of shorter level
and I guess also
on a longer level,
and see people who often
report that they're
doing sport versus people
who often report that they're
drinking, for example.
Some of these things, certainly
the drinking, potentially
has reverse
causality, because it
might be that people drink
because they're stressed.
And it can be awkward, but
with the time series data,
we might have a chance of
addressing some of that,
because you can see
what precedes what.
AUDIENCE: It seems like most
of your data and results
here are from local areas.
Do you have any plans
with the new release
to target the US, Korea,
other industrialized areas?
GEORGE MACKERRON: Right.
So the other thing that I should
have said about Mappiness 2
as well as being
on more platforms
and doing a few more
things is that, yes,
it should be worldwide.
And it would, I guess, have
been a good idea if Mappiness
had been worldwide.
And I have to kind of--
it was quite late in the PhD,
and timezones were really
screwing with my head.
So you can use it.
You can use the original
Mappiness anywhere
in the world.
You just have to
adjust the times.
You'll be beeped in London time.
You know, it's a silly
thing, and probably would've
taken me a day or two and
I could have fixed that.
And then we'd have
had more people.
But I guess the other question
is I couldn't-- you know,
what I was planning to do, the
key thing was to join this with
environmental data
and do research.
And I couldn't promise for
100 countries in the world
that I'd go and find
environmental data
and make that join up.
So I couldn't have
ever said to people,
you'll definitely be
part of the research.
But yeah, definitely
it will be good.
And that would
also, I guess, speak
potentially to this question of
different cultures and so on.
And that would be
interesting to do.
AUDIENCE: Here at Google, we
have a whole people analytics
team.
Have you spoken to them?
GEORGE MACKERRON: No,
but that sounds good.
Yeah, put me in touch.
I'll talk to you afterwards.
That would be great.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry
if you mentioned it.
I missed it.
But did you ask gender question?
Any correlations there?
GEORGE MACKERRON: I haven't
gone into the gender
data in lots of detail.
In terms of natural
environment my recollection
is that there's one small thing
that was slightly at odds,
but largely the nature effects
were kind of fairly consistent
between the genders.
Yeah, we do have that.
As I said, most
of these have been
done with fixed effects,
where you only look
at the individual variation.
So all the effects that pretty
much don't change for anyone
aren't seen.
And in fact, we
don't give people
an opportunity to tell us
that any of those things
have changed, either.
AUDIENCE: Did I see
that the app can--
it prompts you for a
response, but you can also
self decide to respond?
Are there any
differences between these
prompted and self-reported?
GEORGE MACKERRON:
So mostly, I mean,
there's an advantage in letting
people do it at any time, which
is that they feel like
they're in control,
and they can also sort
of show it to people
and show them how it works.
It's a good question.
It's not something
I've focused on.
So generally, we've
just taken the responses
that were prompted, because
the idea of this experience
sampling method is you
want a kind of probability
sample of all the moments
in someone's life.
And of course, they
may have reasons.
They may be showing
it to someone,
or they may be doing it
because they're particularly
happy or particularly unhappy.
So I suspect that you're
right, they would be different.
I guess I'm not 100% sure what
the difference would tell us,
but it would be a thing
that we could look at.
Generally we can take
a response, I think,
that's within an hour of
having being signaled.
And about half of signals get
a response within an hour.
You can reduce that or
increase it, I think.
And in ESM work, typically, it's
sometimes been just 20 minutes.
But then in ESM work,
typically people
have made up half
their responses.
So it's kind of swings
and roundabouts.
It doesn't make a lot of
difference to the effects
that we were looking
at here, whether you
take a really short window or
a really long window, which
is encouraging.
Of course, we are missing
half of people's responses.
And in fact, the
original Mappiness
requires a data
connection to beep you.
It was push notifications,
because local notifications
weren't available.
Which is a shame, because people
up in the middle of nowhere up
a mountain might
be the happiest,
but we can't ding them.
But yeah.
AUDIENCE: Have you seen
anything interesting
as people have aged
through your study?
GEORGE MACKERRON: No.
I guess we could try that.
It would be difficult, though,
I suppose, to disentangle--
I don't know if we've
got a long enough time
series to disentangle you
aging versus the world going up
in flames.
And I mean, in general,
we'd expect a big U shape.
So in the subjective well-being
literature generally,
there's this kind of
big U, where being 40,
45 is the worst.
And then it picks up again.
And some of it
picking up again is
that, again, people retire, and
they're not working anymore.
But that's what
we expect to find.
But I haven't looked
at that in Mappiness.
As I say, I'm not sure if we've
got the best data for that.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
some of these scenarios
where there's a
lot of variability
in terms of happiness
for a single event,
for example having children.
Are there things that are
much more consistent, and then
so maybe the government
could do or companies
could do to improve?
Are there things that
everyone agreed on
as being happy things?
GEORGE MACKERRON: I mean,
one of the interesting things
in relation to economists
normally saying, just
get richer, versus
us thinking are there
unintended consequences
of getting richer?
I mean, certainly one of the
things that springs to mind
is sort of people in city jobs
who get paid vast salaries
but don't have any option at
all except to work full time
or double full time.
I kind of think that
working time regulations are
potentially quite promising.
Now, you know, if you could have
people cut their working hours,
but not have it be a signal
that they weren't committed,
they might do well with four
days instead of five days
and 80% of their salary, say.
The Economics Foundation
have quite a lot
of interesting work about
that, and that potentially
is also kind of good for the
environment, because, you know,
your city lawyer only has a sort
of one weekend in every four
off, and then jets far
away and comes back.
Probably isn't made
very happy by that,
and in addition, they're kind
of using a lot of the world
resources to do it.
Work life balance
issues, potentially.
Yeah, I don't have a
brilliant answer to that.
I mean, redistribution,
potentially.
I showed you this chart
about how little difference
it makes kind of up at
the top end of income,
how much more income you get
compared to how much difference
it makes at the bottom.
And economists are normally
very worried about that.
They're like these
Pareto improvements,
right, where everyone
can agree that if you
can make some people happier
and no one less happy,
then that's great.
But they generally kind of don't
like to talk about the ones
where you make
someone a tiny bit
less happy to make
someone else much happier.
And you know, that's a
difficult political thing.
But that's some of what
politics is about, I suppose.
So there's a thought.
Actually, this is
both my Twitter handle
and GitHub handle.
And probably not worth
going to the Twitter,
because it's just
political ranting.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
Which of the
findings of the study
have surprised you the most?
GEORGE MACKERRON: And
this is the question
that journalists always ask.
Yeah.
Which of the findings have
surprised you the most?
I don't know.
I mean, I guess I'm kind of
used to these findings now.
And the thing
about most of them,
you probably noticed
a couple of times
I was apologizing that
they were kind of obvious.
But the thing that it's
nice is to quantify them
and compare them to each other
and show that they're real.
So there hasn't been much
that has kind of come
completely out of the blue.
No, I'm not sure.
SPEAKER ONE: We have time
for one more question.
Any last question?
If not--
GEORGE MACKERRON: I
mean, to be honest,
the thing that surprised me most
is that 66,000 people wanted
to do this, on average,
for six weeks at a time,
which was wonderful.
And I think they did
that because they learned
about themselves, and
they felt like they
were contributing to a sort
of research enterprise.
So that was good.
AUDIENCE: So this is
my second question,
so I feel like I'm
cheating a bit.
Have you considered
talking to someone
like Facebook, who with a
single slider on the front page
saying how happy are you, could
get you billions and billions
of data points very rapidly?
GEORGE MACKERRON: Yeah.
And during the PhD I did think
about kind of Facebook apps
and that kind of thing.
I haven't approached Facebook.
I know, actually, that
Facebook worked a little bit
with the guy behind
trackyourhappiness.org,
which is a somewhat similar
study based in the States.
I think they have slightly
fewer data points,
and they don't have location.
But otherwise, they had quite
a sort of similar approach
to things.
And I think he actually
works part time there.
It could be worth thinking of.
I suspect that an awful
lot of researchers
are kind of sidling up
to Google and hoping
for that kind of thing too.
So I don't know.
But yeah.
And I guess you'd get this kind
of social network, potentially.
You could sort of trace
through some of the way
that it works through
networks, too,
with that data, which
obviously would be fascinating.
SPEAKER ONE: We are out of time.
Thank you very much,
George MacKerron.
[APPLAUSE]